[Music]
it is seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast and these are our top stories
monitoring the data a new assessment of
omicron expected amidst concerns that
rising cases could still overwhelm the
nhs
what we've seen is nurses being just
physically and mentally exhausted
they're being redeployed they're doing
things that they wouldn't normally be
doing
the lockdown generation growing concerns
for the development of children born
during the pandemic
putin's moment with the media a chance
for him to give a carefully
choreographed message to his own people
and to the west about the state of
russia and his intentions over ukraine
the weather becoming more unsettled for
all of us with milder conditions pushing
in from the
southwest and at a quarter two we'll
take another look at the papers with the
journalist and author janelle aldridge
and the broadcaster anne diamond
[Music]
morning all we are due to get some fresh
data on the severity of the omicron
variant of covet from the uk health
security agency later after two studies
suggested it may cause milder illness
than the delta variant scientists say
the findings are good news but warning
surging cases could yet overwhelm the
nhs
well yesterday saw a record day for
covid cases with more than a hundred
thousand reported as wales and northern
ireland announced further restrictions
coming into effect after christmas
for his part boris johnson has yet to
indicate if he will follow suit in
england skies santia choudhury has our
first report
record new cases in a day and a record
number of vaccines administered the race
against covid is neck and neck
so today you're going to get the final
vaccine okay
um
this gp surgery in stretton a sign that
the vaccine is gaining support
we've had a lot of people come forward
for the first dose now so i think some
of those people that were relying on
herd immunity or just hoping to wait out
have realized that kobe's not going
anywhere anytime soon the uk's health
security agency has confirmed another 13
581 new cases of the omicron variant
bringing the total number to over 74
000.
it's enough to put holiday plans on
notice i am supposed to be going to
visit my girlfriend in romania in
january and that is looking like it
might be a job this year i'm not even
getting enrolled in christmas i'm not
getting hungry
holiday plans up in the air but some
positive news is emerging about hospital
stays a major study from scotland
estimates a 56 reduction in risk of
hospitalization there with omicron
compared to delta
researchers in london looking at english
data came up with a similar number those
with omicron 40 to 45 percent less
likely to spend a night or more in
hospital compared to delta infections
overall people were 15 to 20 percent
less likely to go to hospital at all
with omicron in england
but even if it's milder if the number of
cases is high enough it could still be a
problem for an nhs already under strain
so what we've seen is nurses being just
physically and mentally exhausted um
they're being redeployed they're doing
things that they wouldn't normally be
doing people are trying to cover the
work of one two three four colleagues
that might be missing experts have
welcomed the research but urge caution
given how small the sample in the
scotland study is and how early in the
omicron outbreak we are sadia chowdhury
sky news
well let's bring you the latest data on
coronavirus and as mentioned 106 122 new
cases of copen 19 were reported in the
latest 24-hour period 140 more people
have died taking the total number of
those who've lost their lives within 28
days of a positive test to 147
573.
at vaccines while they did hit a new
high yesterday more than 968
665 boosters and third jabs were given
when you add in first and second jabs
more than a million vaccines given in a
single day almost 31 million people have
now had a third jab or booster
covered infections among primary
school-aged children are estimated to be
three times higher than in the general
population the government-backed react
one study has found that around four and
a half percent of five to
eleven-year-olds have the virus
compared to just one and a half percent
across the country
i was bringing a little bit more on the
latest cover data the react one team
from imperial college london uh now
completing the latest round of their
study looking at the prevalence of the
virus across the country uh we're joined
now by professor paul elliott director
of the react program and chair in
epidemiology and public health medicine
at imperial college london great to see
you at this morning professor um it is
again a fascinating piece of research
let's let's start with that which
everyone has has latched on to how much
more do we know about omicron
well what we've seen in our data is um
that we've had
since the summer really quite high
prevalence but but pretty steady with
the r number around one
uh but from the beginning of december we
saw this very dramatic rise in uh
prevalence across the country but
particularly in london
with the r number now substantially
above one so this exponential increase
in infections which is
absolutely being driven by the omicron
variant
just in terms of of what that means in
terms of the public health strategy in
terms of pressure on the nhs you will
have seen i'm sure some of the front
pages this morning and everyone focusing
very very quickly on the fact that that
it certainly appears that this is
significantly
significantly less severe that there is
a reduced chance of hospitalization as a
result i mean how confident are we in
that
well of course that's encouraging news
uh
that perhaps the
infection when you get it might be
less severe in in terms of
hospitalization
but of course with this very very rapid
rise and increase in cases and we've
seen the the national cases go above 100
000 and of course uh
more cases means more pressure because
if if uh even though a smaller
proportion might go
get severe disease or go into hospital
that could still result in in many cases
and of course that could give pressure
on the health service
of course i mean just just very simply
put despite the fact that omicron may
prove to be significantly less severe in
individual kind of health outcomes that
does not mean that the nhs will not be
under huge pressure perhaps in a couple
of weeks time
absolutely the case because
this rise in
in infections uh which we see in our
data and is seen also in the
testing data through through the
national routine testing of people
presenting with symptoms means that
there are going to be well there are you
know many many cases and
sadly some of those people may get
severe illness and end up in hospital
of course this data will assist um other
pieces of research the modeling that are
around um covert 19 and of course the on
the new the new variant
a number of people are suggesting that
the spy m models
were quite pessimistic
they would need to be revised on the
basis of of what you have discovered is
is that correct
yeah i mean what we're doing is
uh we're looking actually in real time
so our data was up until
the 14th of december with some
additional
cases up until the 17th of december and
we're looking in the general population
so we take a random sample of the
population of england and ask people to
take part and give us a swab and answer
some questions about their symptoms and
so forth so we get a really good picture
of what's happening in the population in
real time and of course that's extremely
helpful so we're not modeling forward
we're looking at what's happening in the
here and now and here and now as i say
we've seen this very rapid rise in
infections which is being driven by the
omicron variant
but of course it will be a piece of
research that the government would look
at in terms of you know plotting their
their strategy moving forward i i wonder
though if we could just focus just for a
second on on children the idea that 4.5
infected there compared to 1.5
nationally
do we do we know why that is is it
simply you know the lack of vaccination
well we we we if we have a if you like a
sort of natural experiment because the
younger children have not been
vaccinated so this is the primary
school-aged children whereas
the older children from 12 and above
have been
receiving vaccine and and in our data
certainly uh a good proportion of them
have been vaccinated and very
interestingly what we saw from our
previous survey which ended on the 5th
of november to the current survey
which was between the 23rd of november
and the 15th of december we saw a drop
by about half of the infection rate in
the older school children
um but the youngest children you're
talking about their prevalence remained
about the same about five percent
so so we do see the the real benefits of
the vaccination program in those older
school children coming through in the
data that we're collecting
what does the what does the research
show about about those who have yet to
be vaccinated we know that there are
parts of london for example where
perhaps as many as 40 percent of the
population haven't had a single jab
there must be concern about what might
be happening there
yes certainly in our data the the real
the really big rise in december with
with omicron has been in london it's
it's sort of in the vanguard if you like
of this of this variant
and um
of the ten
local small areas uh
lower tier local authority areas that
we're we're we're monitoring
of the 10 with the highest eight of
those are in london
so we really are seeing this in london
um professor just whilst we have you i
wonder if i might ask you to kind of
remove your professorial hat just for a
second um
on the basis of the the research that
has been carried out as we edge into to
2022 past couple of years have been
pretty rough for everyone are you
feeling more or less positive about what
might be coming down the track as a
result of this
uh to be honest we were really quite
positive about the roll out of the
vaccine program which has been obviously
a fantastic success
uh we are seeing that in our data not
only in the um
secondary school-aged children but
actually in older people over the age of
65 we've seen a real drop in infections
in that group
again reflecting
the booster program where most of those
people have had a booster so it was
really looking
looking promising
and of course now we've got this variant
and uh
and this very very sharp rise in
infection so for the time being
i would say that uh we all have to be a
bit cautious
and we have to pay attention to the
public health message we have to wear
our mask and so forth
because um you know these are
unprecedented levels of infection
they certainly are um professor paul
elliott great to have you on the program
this morning and a very merry christmas
to you and yours when it comes thanks
very much thank you
now a generation of locked-down babies
children born during the pandemic are
starting to show the impact of their far
from ordinary early life isolation
lockdowns even mask wearing all taking
their toll as the children begin their
nursery education
and it's feared that language speech
therapy and child development services
could be stretched to breaking point as
guys becky johnson reports
once upon a time there are three little
pigs who live with their mother the
story familiar to generations of
children should we count the pigs one
but for this generation childhood has so
far been very different not by the hair
on my chinny chin chin
too young to remember life before the
pandemic
lockdowns were imposed at a crucial
stage in their development
nurseries including this one in
birmingham are seeing the impact they
are
you know slightly delayed in some sort
in some of their language and
communication skills and
interactions with their peers so you
know following rules and boundaries
we've had to do a lot of work um you
know with that what do you need to say
lovely sharing through the various
lockdowns children this age have missed
out on so many months of normal
childhood that they're having to be
taught some of the social skills that we
normally just expect children will learn
through play and interaction
experts believe it'll have a long-term
effect on their education with
disadvantaged children suffering the
most
we will see consequences in one form or
another that will last
for four years
and will impact on their trajectory also
of learning in the future we'd be
looking at the sentence that the child
can say so the girl is sitting on the
box speech therapist stephanie ropic is
having to help children make up for time
lost in lockdown
a lot of parents having to work from
home and not being able to interact as
much with their children during that
time lack of opportunities to play and
mix with their peers
in the inner city primary schools where
she works demand has soared
in birmingham in the schools i work in
probably seeing
80 of the children starting reception
with
not age-appropriate language skills
and how does that compare to
pre-pandemic
maybe about 40 percent
that's doubled
yeah and that also nearly every child
yeah in reception in the schools i work
at it is most of the children
as evidence builds of the impact on
young children the full consequences may
not be known for many years
becky johnson sky news birmingham
the russian president vladimir putin
will give his end-of-year news
conference this morning inviting
selected friendly journalists to put
questions to him all coming at a time of
course of increased tension between
moscow and the west over what nato
believes could be an imminent russian
invasion of ukraine our moscow
correspondent dianna magni joins us now
good to see you this morning diana it is
that most wonderful time of the year
isn't it when we all sit to find out
exactly how long vladimir putin is going
to talk for what's the sweepstake in the
office saying this year
i say three and a half my cameras that
man says four and a half
so i'm hoping that i win this time but
we have no money on it um but you're
right that this is a carefully
choreographed event with journalists
hand-picked by the kremlin this time
round and the fact that for example nova
the independent newspaper whose editor
just won the nobel peace prize for
defense of journalism has not been
accredited tells you i think all you
need to know about the state of the free
media in russia
but of course for the west it will be
most significant what president putin
has to say about ukraine he made some
pretty ominous comments on tuesday
saying that if nato does not stop its
aggressive stance and of course nato
says that it is purely a defensive uh
organization if nato does not stop its
aggressive stance then russia will be
forced to use military technical means
to combat it and what we believe he
means by that what the foreign ministry
has
suggested he means by that is the
redeployment in europe
on russian territory of
intermediate-range missiles which could
of course reach european capitals which
were banned under the inf treaty but now
that that treaty has been dissolved
may start being replaced in europe
against the background to all this of
course is this russian military buildup
across along russia's border with
ukraine the concerns in
ukraine and in the west that vladimir
putin may invade and these security
proposals that
russia has published which set a really
very high bar outlining a potential new
security architecture that russia would
like to see in europe there is a lot in
there that clearly won't be realized for
example vetoing any future accession of
ukraine to nato but there are probably
areas where there could be negotiations
started on for example arms control
military exercises negotiations are due
to start early next year will be
interesting to see it and hugely
important of course to see whether that
is actually what vladimir putin
wants to achieve a new security
architecture or whether he does have his
sights on
invading ukraine
uh much more from you of course
throughout the morning uh diana for now
thanks very much indeed
uh other news now and the jury in the
trial of delane maxwell has been sent
home for the christmas break
jurors entered ended their second full
day of deliberations into the sex
trafficking trial without reaching a
verdict it means that maxwell who was
herself born on christmas day will spend
her 60th birthday in prison
nearly half of people say they plan to
travel to visit family and friends this
christmas and that could mean chaos on
the roads there'll be an estimated 10
million journeys today and tomorrow with
it set to be the busiest getaway for
five years
a rather different story on the trains
however expected to be used by only one
in ten travelers
hundreds of trains are actually set to
be cancelled because of pandemic related
staff shortages and a strike by the rmt
union also likely to lead to the
cancellation of many cross-country
services tomorrow with further action
expected after christmas
it is a strange world when mcdonald's
runs out of fries but they're being
forced to ration them in japan because
of a bottleneck and supplies caused by
the covered pandemic medium and large
servings of mcdonald's fries are off the
menu customers are only allowed just a
small portion
the vast majority of women believe that
services for conditions only affecting
women are given a lower priority by
health professionals well today the
government sets out its plans for
tackling gender inequality uh joining us
now skies millennial vessel in which
who's in the newsroom morning again
melania take us through this where's
this research from good morning neil
well more than 110 000 responses were
collected from individual women as well
as organizations between june
march and june this year and they found
that eight in ten women found that
healthcare professionals simply don't
listen to them and that the conditions
that affect only women are given far
less priority than other conditions now
two in three women who have a disability
or a special condition said that
basically uh that they don't feel
supported by the services available and
then the majority of women believed that
compulsory training for gps on women's
issues was including the menopause was
needed in order for their needs to be
met now the minister for women's health
maria corville called some of these
findings shocking there are steps the
government is taking to try to improve
this for example including
demographic data or all respondents of
research trials into
that information they will also be
banning hymenoplasty now that is a
procedure to restore a woman's hymen it
is linked to virginity testing and
experts say that it is
perpetuating very outdated views on
women's sexuality and furthermore the
government has already pledged to outlaw
virginity tests
thank you
time to see how the weather is looking
as we nudge towards christmas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the unsettled conditions stay with us
into christmas weekend and beyond with
the mild air battling the cold for
dominance it is a chilly start in the
north and east icy stretches are
possible in northern scotland but it's
much milder in the west the rain spreads
in across ireland into western parts of
the uk and will then merge with the
existing rain belt over scotland
increasing the risk of hill snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's stick with covid could the rising
number of omicron cases lead to a
circuit breaker lockdown after christmas
and would that circuit breaker include
closing schools we're joined now by
george budd principal of morton hall
school in shropshire uh good to see you
this morning mr birdsee i've already
fallen into the habit there of calling
you by your teacher's name george good
to see you this morning and look we've
got plenty to discuss about what what
might be coming down the road in in 2022
but let's just start with a few
reflections i mean how was 2021 for you
you colleagues and your pupils
morning neil and yes thank you very much
for the opportunity to come on this
morning it was it was a challenging year
i think that we learned an awful lot in
2020 in 2020 the first few months the
pandemic so that come you know come 20
20 uh 2021 with the start of the
academic year we were in a very
different place uh in terms of things
like switching easily to online learning
uh sort of know dealing with the sort of
challenges which kovid crops up so i
think from that point of view you know
every school in the land i think would
find itself in the same position there
um we fortunately because we're a
relatively rural school we've actually
found uh not a huge amount of disruption
this year i think we've been quite
fortunate although i know of course many
of my colleagues running running schools
in cities or running schools and that
are not boarding schools we're
predominantly a boarding school have
found things rather different and so it
has been a more positive year and for me
it's really underlined the importance as
we you know we've already heard this
morning about 80 percent of reception
children joining the uh joining that
class with lower than expected levels of
language and i think for me it's this
year has underlined the importance of
keeping our children in school
yeah and just in terms of the kids
themselves i mean obviously there's been
testing for some of them there will have
been there will be vaccination going on
i mean how are they coping with this i
mean i remember when i was kind of you
know my mid-teens if something like this
had come up and come along it would have
knocked us all for six
i think you know children are hugely
resilient and i think they adapt very
quickly to to changing circumstances and
we've seen that throughout the last 18
months you know when we went online the
the resilience and determination of our
boys and girls to you know to carry on
with their learning and to make the best
of that situation about which they could
do little or nothing um was really
remarkable and that's continued actually
this year um and you know i think young
people are very resilient and very
quick to to adapt to changing sets of
circumstances so probably than most of
the adults so in many ways from that
that point of view i'm quite optimistic
that and indeed it's been reflecting
what we've seen this year i'm quite
optimistic that you know the sort of
normal routine of school life normal
rhythm will come back very quickly and
we've actually seen this year you know
to give you a couple of examples i think
that the my you know my first lacrosse
team for example they've been much more
a much more knitted group this year than
i think than perhaps we'd expected
because i think children coming back
into school they're so determined to to
rekindle those friendships that of
course have been so difficult to keep
going via a screen and i think that's if
that was one thing that we were worried
about how
are children going to reintegrate with
each other socially but actually we've
seen the complete opposite of that and
they've been hugely positive and hugely
determined to you know to to get back to
life as normal
i i suppose though the the dark cloud
for any pupil of of secondary age in or
out of a viral pandemic or exams now
they are fast looming on the horizon
we've been discussing of course
potential circuit breakers potential
school lockdowns i mean from your
perspective
could the kids cope with with an
extended period away from school again
back on to the remote learning
i think could they cope yes is it the
right thing for them no
you know children need to be in school
for so many reasons they can learn
academically relatively effectively at
home uh you know we can as we we we're
in the position now the government is
providing a lot of laptops where schools
are geared up for it and so i think the
you know for the academic delivery uh is
perhaps far reason it was of course
there is still huge disparity between um
people of you know people who are more
deprived people who lack access to
online education at home people whose
parents are perhaps less available to
help them at home but you know the
bottom line is could the children code
yes is it the best thing for them
absolutely not and i think um
we heard the other day that 90 percent
of people in hospital who are receiving
the most care in hospital are
unvaccinated and so i would implore all
of the adults who are able to get
vaccinated to please go and do so
because you know keep protecting the nhs
is often given as the reason why we may
have another circuit breaker lockdown
and you know learning that 90 percent of
people who are receiving the most care
in hospital are in fact unvaccinated
that people could do something about
that and from a from the point of view
as a head teacher as a teacher i would
implore them to do so because that will
keep their children in school where they
learn the best
uh well george wishing you your
colleagues your pupils all the very best
for 2022 and uh look have a lovely
christmas when it comes thanks for
joining us thanks
bye-bye
time for us to have a quick look at the
morning sport
wow calm down johnny it's only a game
brought to you by vitality sharing the
benefits of healthy living
and liverpool needed a great performance
from their second choice goalkeeper to
beat leicester on penalties and thus
reach the semi-finals of the league cup
quiving kelleher saved two penalties
including this one from leicester's ryan
bertrand and sudden death after the
match had ended three all that left
diogo jota to score the winning penalty
screen on that one as liverpool won the
shootout 5-4 setting up a semi-final
against arsenal keller well he's only 23
years
old meanwhile in the other semi
tottenham will face chelsea lucas mura
scoring the winner as tottenham beat
west ham 2-1 in their quarterfinal
means that tottenham boss antonio conte
faces his old club chelsea who beat
brentford two nil this
own goal or helping them to victory it
is their third semi-final in 11 months
[Applause]
an absolute shocker from celtic in the
scottish premiership second place celts
drawing nil nil at st mirren despite
having more than 30 shots on goal the
top division will be taking an early
winter break which will then start after
the boxing day games
handball handball
handball ref handball riff
coming up next on breakfast i'll be
speaking to dame esther ransom as an
unprecedented number of people facing
loneliness this christmas
[Music]
welcome back a leading scientist says
that new studies showing the omicron
variant is less severe and less likely
to send people to hospital is
encouraging news professor paul elliot
the chair in epidemiology and public
health medicine at imperial college
london which published one of the
reports well he says the extent of the
outbreak could still overwhelm the nhs
this rise in
infections which we see in our data and
is seen also in the
testing data through through the
national routine testing of people
presenting with symptoms means that
there are going to be well there are you
know many many cases and
sadly some of those people may get
severe illness and end up in hospital
uh let's bring our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen from
westminster um tomorrow the the picture
being painted there by professor elliot
we understand why all the front pages
this morning are carrying at those
studies showing that omicron perhaps
less severe than delta however as he
makes perfectly clear there could still
be some significant perhaps even
debilitating pressures on the health
service that's right there is some
tentative good news from this imperial
study and a separate study in scotland
which both found that your risk of
needing to go to hospital and stay in
hospital if you have omicron is much
reduced compared to delta so that is
great news however it is qualified by
the fact that omicron is spreading
incredibly fast so that that might wipe
out all the gains from it being less
severe because so many people will get
omicron that you might still have very
high numbers of people with severe
disease having to go to hospital and
that's threatening to overwhelm the nhs
so what this means in terms of possible
restrictions in england which is the
only part of the uk which is where no
restrictions after christmas have been
announced the scottish welsh and
northern irish first ministers have all
announced restrictions from boxing day
or the day after but boris johnson is
holding out um significantly because
members of his cabinet and members of uh
his party are very vocally against
restrictions and many of them will seize
on this new data to say look perhaps we
don't need them now i'm told today by
senior sources in government that we do
not expect that to change boris johnson
is not going to be announcing any more
restrictions for after christmas this
week we will not hear from him about
that this week but of course they will
be assessing very carefully all the
hospitalization data that's coming in to
see how fast those hospitalizations are
rising
tamara thank you
now for many of us the festive season is
all about getting together with friends
and family and sharing time together but
it's thought that almost one million
older people will spend christmas alone
with a further five million saying the
best present they could get this year
would be a phone call from a loved one
damn esther ransom who's founded the
silver line to offer support to those
who need it joins us on the program
esther it's lovely to see you on the
program this morning i do hope you're
very very well but it is a sad topic
that you and i will once again reflect
on it can be a very very lonely time of
year for some people
it can but it is amazing and it is
wonderful news how much difference a
simple bit of technology that looks a
bit like this
can make
to that christmas day i'll be talking to
um
well probably about 10 people on
christmas day who've asked for a phone
call
and i have uh done this for a um a
number of previous christmases and i can
tell you that
the difference in people's voices at the
end of a conversation that if you can
laugh together about some
excuse me some memory of christmas is
past it can make a huge difference to
the whole day so i would say if you've
got
half an hour or so just pick up the
phone and bring someone in your family
someone whom maybe you've known in a
past life an old school friend an old
neighbor and say that you've been
thinking of them and you want to wish
them a very good
2022.
and of course esther you have perhaps
done more work than most people in this
area with with the silver line you've
offered a
reassuring words to to any number of
people of a certain age at this time of
year but
what's been fascinating to me this
morning is i didn't really know the back
story to the line can you just tell our
viewers a little bit about it
well
when i wrote about um feelings of
loneliness that i was experiencing i was
inundated with letters and i got
a file of them here because um i
obviously obviously i've kept them but
there's one in particular that inspired
me from a gentleman called pablo he said
i'm 90.
my wife died three months ago of
alzheimer's disease after 65 years of
marriage but more to the point 72 years
since we first kissed and she waited
throughout the war for me and i for her
loneliness tell me about it and he
included a poem
well i was so struck by that amazing
letter that i got in touch with him and
asked if he'd be prepared when we
launched the sill line to become our
first ambassador and so at the age of 90
he started on a whole new role going all
over the country and also reading that
poem which went all over the world about
his love for kath and his loneliness and
having missed her well he was due to be
100 years old we were all going to
celebrate his birthday tuesday of this
week alas he died a couple of weeks ago
so we celebrated his birthday
and had a memorial service
this tuesday
and it was a remarkable
event because everybody talked about how
much he'd done
to counteract the loneliness of older
people through his work and i i would
just like to say
two things really neil one is
i think we should all remember people
who've lost someone close to them this
christmas because
christmas time is particularly hard if
like the queen you're used to spending
it with the closest person in your life
and you've lost them and i remember that
the first christmas after i lost my
husband
so i want to say that we're all thinking
of people who've lost someone precious
to them and we know it's going to be
really tough this christmas
but i'd also like to say that
it's never too late to start a new role
a new career and have a new adventure
bob showed it at the age of 90.
and my happiness neil is that i was able
to see him before he died
and he did say to me
he said i would have liked to make a
hundred and i said bob
according to the chinese calendar
you have made a hundred because they
start with conception and i think that
cheered him up a bit
i think i i'm sure it did what what what
a legacy um bob leaves and indeed what a
testament and a tribute to the love he
had for kath and esther we have to leave
it there but i wonder just as we say our
goodbyes i saw you hold up the memorial
the other can we have a quick look at
the photo of bob and cath that's on the
front there
yes absolutely stunning day mr ransom
always an absolute pleasure to talk to
you you look after yourself and have a
very very lovely christmas lots of love
from all of us here and the same to you
neil and the same to your whole team
and if you know any you or anyone you
know is indeed struggling over the
festive season and indeed throughout the
year at the number below is for silver
line oh 800 470 1890 that works to
support those who are experiencing
loneliness that number again oh 800 4 70
80 90.
now it is set to be the busiest day on
the roads as people get away for the
holidays with just one in 10 choosing to
use public transport
joining us now the president of the a.a
edmund king edmund great to see you i do
hope you are well um can we just start
with why we think the roads are going to
be so busy this year why are so many
people seemingly abandoning public
transport
in favor of getting constantly asked for
hours on end are we there yet
yes good morning neil we did a survey of
15 000 people about three weeks ago and
from that survey we asked them would
they be traveling today tomorrow over
the christmas period and we found about
the equivalent of about 18 million
drivers would be traveling today and
tomorrow to get away
and i think a couple of reasons one is
because obviously there were more
restrictions in place last year so many
people didn't spend christmas with their
families
but i do think the other reason is
people are more cautious of public
transport um
with the virus out there and therefore
they feel a bit safer in in the bubble
of their own car now obviously since we
did that survey about three weeks ago
there have been more concerns raised
about the virus so so i think we we
would slightly downgrade those figures
but even so i think we'll see the roads
getting busier today and then
tomorrow particularly around lunchtime
when when people rush to get to see
family and friends
yeah and i suppose of course you know
traveling at this time of year you know
you always have to be mindful of the
weather you know i've been reading it
out all morning and it doesn't look like
it's going to be the worst but you know
people will be taking roads that they're
unfamiliar with routes that they're
unfamiliar with i mean what's the best
advice
before packing the bags into the back of
the car and stuffing the kids in there
as well
yeah there's some really good advice
because what we actually find even with
breakdowns about 40 of people struggle
to actually describe where they are i'm
on the a5 i'm going towards kendall i
went past the quarry about a mile away
but i'm not sure where i am and what
we're saying to people there's this free
uh app called what three words and it
divides the globe in into 70 trillion uh
three meter squares and every three
meter square has three words that
describe where it is
so rather than saying you're near
kendall if you actually phoned this up
and gave the three words stall
squeaking and fended we would know
exactly where you are
so we we're using that i think we've
used it about 5 000 times in the last
week where people haven't known where
they are
and and probably more importantly for
the emergency services if someone has
had a crash particularly in a remote
area a rural area
knowing that what three words for that
area means the emergency services can
can get there quickly so hopefully that
will help in people's preparations and
also we know over the next couple of
days people are still get getting out
there to get booster jabs so we've just
agreed with grant chaps and the
department of transport that will put up
more a.a temporary signs to these
community vaccination centers so you
know hopefully a little preparation from
drivers preparing the car preparing
themselves planning their journey before
they go checking traffic before they go
will help lead towards smoother journeys
this christmas
some very useful advice edmund king from
the a lovely to see you again and have a
lovely christmas when you get there same
to you neil thank you very much
stay where you are as we approach
quarter two after the break we'll be
taking another look at the papers with
the journalist and author janelle
aldridge and the broadcaster anne
diamond as next
[Music]
uh time to have a look at the papers
once again uh joining us to give us
their selections the journalist and
author janelle aldridge and the
broadcaster anne diamond lovely to see
you both again um janelle to you first
this time because obviously we like to
switch it up and about and it's the
front page of the mirror and this is
all to do with those young people who
might not have had a jab just yet
no yeah and whilst we talked you know in
the last hour about omicron being milder
for unvaccinated people people who
aren't for vaccinated people people who
aren't vaccinated while some of them are
facing higher risk and this says 80 of
patients at the royal liverpool hospital
are unvaccinated so it's healthy people
30s early 40s you know four out of five
of their patients haven't had the
vaccine and so although we know it's not
as severe as alfred delta omicron it's
spreading more quickly which means
you're more likely to catch it and if
you're not vaccinated that can spell
trouble and i think it's we have to tell
the story that two things can be true
that one is not as severe as we thought
but two if you aren't vaccinated then it
can still potentially be deadly for you
and so we you know that's the message
that i think we really need to keep
saying i mean and as you take us to to
the front of the daily telegraph i mean
obviously last this hour we spoke with
professor paul elliot from from imperial
college behind that react survey and
and as janelle was suggesting look it is
great it's positive news that this is
not going to have the most severe health
outcomes for most people but if lots of
people get it there could still be an
awful lot of pressure on the health
service and that also throws us forward
into 2022 and what we do next about
potentially a fourth boost a fourth shot
in our arms
that's right i mean uh the those of us
who are right up with our vaccines and
and want a lot
um uh sort of could be due for asking
whether we are are going to be due for a
second booster i for instance had my
booster at the end of september so at
the end of december just in a few days
time it'll have been three months and my
age group are all asking themselves
should we be asking for a second booster
and they are bringing out a second
booster or if you like a fourth dose um
in israel and germany they've they're
going ahead with the fourth booster or
fourth dose whatever you want to call it
um and this report here says that um
they are seriously considering the jcbi
here uh the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization are
seriously considering it now they're
looking for a bit more data um but it
looks as though they're going to go the
same way and say all right because what
we are seem to be uh recognizing is that
the potency of the vaccine wanes over
time could be three months could be four
months when most of us will need a
booster again um and if that's true uh
and if the jcbi do recommend it then we
could be going ahead with that second
booster as early as the new year for
some it's already available for people
uh with weakened immunity and other
disorders um but for the general
population starting presumably with
older people um yes a fourth dose a
second booster could be available in the
new year yeah so it certainly feels as
if those those booster jabs are going to
be with us for for many years to come um
janelle take us inside the guardian the
article with the headline return of the
mat a reference to one hit wonder mark
morrison i mean i don't think that's a
reference that many necessarily of the
guardians readers will get tell us about
the story though
well it's the man that boris called
totally hopeless with an explicit
expletive in there in a whatsapp message
last year so it seems that matt hancock
is keen on making a comeback um what
kind of comeback we don't know i mean
he's had the unseeable cctv embrace we
saw he was at the number 10 cheese and
winegate party allegedly although he
said he's not clear it's him and i think
if someone's not clear if it's them in a
photo we do wonder in public life what
they are capable of and also he had the
job offer at the un overturned he was at
itv with phil and holly you know he's
something about power that seems to be
alluring him and pulling him back but i
think he's had a few more comebacks than
mike tyson and i'm not sure whether a
full return to a ministerial capacity or
full public life is really seriously on
the cards for him although he seems to
think it might be i'm sure matt hancock
would appreciate being compared to mike
tyson of all people i mean it's just
just just on this topic though janelle i
mean is it ever worthwhile for a
politician who's suffered such very
public and obvious disgrace to try and
invade their way back into frontline
politics
i think he should if i were him i would
be asking myself some very serious
questions really about the um competency
that people might see in me and
therefore believe the things that i do
and say and take me seriously you know
we want to take our politicians
seriously we want to believe the things
that they say and unfortunately for him
he's been caught in a steady stream of
compromising situations where it seems
that we can't trust what he says and we
can't trust what he does and so he might
want to return to power but i think the
question for every mp and public servant
is is it good for them to be in power
and that's the question i think he
should ask himself and you look you look
like you're pretty settled for christmas
the decorations are wonderful behind you
are you are yeah are you going to be
doing are you going to be doing any
driving it looks like if people are
hitting the roads this year it's going
to be very very busy indeed
it really is i mean if you're not
already there get going now i say
because it really does look as though
it's going to be mayhem and a lot of the
newspapers are reflecting that this
morning um you've got the busier
apparently it's going to be busiest on
the roads for years probably because a
lot of people don't want to take public
transport uh they prefer to stay within
their own bubble and that's
understandable and also because they had
such a grotty christmas last year unable
to travel and see friends and family
that this year they are determined to so
it is going to be a very long drive
wherever you're going to drive
you know take sandwiches and coffee with
you or something i don't know make sure
you're warm and you've got enough petrol
in the car um because the rsc says 5.3
million people are going to get behind
the wheel on christmas eve they're
already driving today 18 million cars
are going to be on the roads over the
christmas weekend and meanwhile i mean
if you're thinking of flying and you are
aren't you um heathrow airport is going
to be pretty awful because it is
actually going to be cut off from tube
and train links over the weekend because
of rail works meanwhile you've also got
industrial action on the trains that are
running or are not running now um and uh
16 trains a day have been taken out um
until christmas eve because of covid
shortages so uh it is going to be hell
on the roads uh and traveling anywhere
this weekend so set off early and
imagine the worst prepare for the worst
um
thanks thanks thank you anne for
depressing the hell out of all of us uh
janelle why don't you improve our mood
by giving us the story of a sausage dog
who balances things in his head great
story this
so this is the content i think we need
this christmas to cheer us all up
sausage dog harzo he he poses like elf
on a shelf on his head um he also
recreates well i don't think he does his
owners help him to recreate the iconic
love actually film scene and i think
people are agreed that he's the content
that we need because he's got 200 000
followers on instagram that's way more
than me so so clearly him in all of
these poses is causing us lots of fun
and i think um in a tough year and a
tough christmas uh these kind of fun
pictures are always going to raise a bit
of a smile his name is halzo and i have
to say just looking at the pictures
there
i'm going to gently suggest that i don't
think he's entirely happy with this i
think he looks quite annoyed and sausage
dogs i've nearly lost a finger to them a
couple of times over the years um
janelle and we will see you again in the
eight o'clock our brilliant selection
there we will see you in just a few
minutes time uh but you can stay right
where you are coming up after the break
we will again be reflecting on that new
research suggesting that omicron may be
significantly less severe in its health
outcomes than delta
[Music]